welcome to all our viewers i'm anjali
from simply learn and today i'll be
taking you through the installation
process for docker so before we begin
let me give you an intro to docker so
what is docker docker is a tool which is
used to automate the deployment of
applications in lightweight containers
so when i say containers i mean a
software package that consists of all
the dependencies required to run the
particular application and when you
deploy containers you're basically
providing the capability for the
application to run in any kind of
environment so dockers have multiple
features some of which are that multiple
containers can run on the same hardware
it has very high productivity when
compared to virtual machines it
maintains isolated applications and has
a very quick and easy configuration
process so now let's begin with the demo
we'll be installing docker on an ubuntu
system so this is my system i just
opened the terminal so the first thing
you can start with is removing any
docker installation that you probably
already have present in your system if
you want to start from scratch so this
is the command to do so sudo apt get
remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo apt get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the suru
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker io
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version
17.12.1 ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull
an image from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a docker image which
is present on the docker hub docker hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now
the command to check this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system
and this means that our docker is
working
now we'll try out another command
sudo docker ps minus a
this displays all the containers that
you have pulled so far so as you can see
here there are three hello world images
displayed and all of them are in exited
state so i did this demo previously too
which is why the two hello worlds which
is created two minutes ago is also
displayed here and the first hello world
which has been created a minute ago is
the one we just did for this demo now as
you have probably noticed that all the
hello world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state
and with that we come to an end of our
docker installation so i hope you all
really liked the video if you did please
hit the like button and also subscribe
to our channel if you haven't yet as we
have many more videos coming up for you
if you have any doubts regarding docker
please post them in the comment section
below and we will definitely get back to
you so see you all next time this is
anjali signing off
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here